hello there I'm Gavin done and this
slow-mo video is another one about car
safety we did airbags this is a seatbelt
pretensioners
yeah so I've got one type here which is
a pre-loaded spring what's going to
happen is when you crash this loaded
spring gets released putting on a cable
here which is attached to a seatbelt and
that pulls the seatbelt down then
pulling you into your seat so you're
going to see stops the bottom half of
you from sliding away yeah this one uses
a spring this one uses explosives so I'm
more excited about this one to be honest
we'll get this one out the way yeah and
then move on to the explosives and that
it's going to fire from here so I think
we should load this over the paint we
can put something in there yeah we're
going to film this with two cameras one
is the Phantom flex 4k for a maximum
resolution resolution and for speed
we're going to use the Phantom b25 11
which we'll be shooting at 28,000 frames
per second speed
what you put in the tree this was too
weak to pull it goodness all right I
guess we're not doing that one we've
moved on to the explosive one because
the spring one we couldn't set it off
get some paint on this one you think
yeah
all right loading up with red paint well
ah
that way wrap it up that's very fast
really quick commit scare that one yeah
yeah it's just so quick oh that was a
great blood gun yeah I'm glad we use the
faster camera jeez
yeah that was hardly showed anything was
wrap it yeah
all right let's see this one shows a lot
more it's amazing how much I don't
believe in 20,000 frames a second adds
to it to a shot it literally just you
see the puff of the explosive smoke
coming out the back which goes to the
smoke on this one yeah that's so clear
and the shotgun that's even better
that was really quick wasn't it smells
good yeah I was gonna say you can resell
the explosive toasters I am always blown
away by the amount of explosives that
are sat in a car which is ready to save
your life with airbags and these they
look very together that right with their
sabers like it's so cool you know where
the ejector seats on helicopters and
planes have explosives in them all
around the edge yeah
that's it get blown up good quick we
should do one of them yeah we shoot you
up as a really interesting video that
was cool
I've more trust in cars now yeah well
hope you enjoyed that feel free to
follow us on Twitter subscribe to the
channel there's loads of videos buy a
shirt you look better in slow-mo that's
peerage it we'll see you next time do
that
broke now anyway wish I was filming that
what just happened I just dropped in it
by ha ha ha